‏r
[Silence]
ال
السلام
علكم
make
‏pleas
[Silence]
make
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
السلام الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد
ان
اله الا
الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محم
رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه
حي على
[Silence]
الصلاه
حي على
[Silence]
الفلا حي على
الفلا
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ان الحمد لله
نحمده الله ونؤمن به ونسترشده
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئ
ا من يهد الله فهو
المت ومن يضل فلن تجد له وليا
مرشدا واشهد ان اله الا
الله الله وحده لا شريك
له واشهد ان محمدا صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم عبده
ورسوله محمد صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم الله عباد الله الله اوصيكم ونفسي
المذنبه بتقوى
الله الله الله سبحانه وتعالى قران اعوذ
بالله من الشيطان الرجيم يا ايها الذين
امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا
وانم
الله سبحانه
وتالى
ضان
month
mon mon mercy
fore from
thead الله سبهالى
الله سبحانه وتالى يا ا الذين امنوا كتب
عليكم الصيام كما كما كتب على الذين من
قبلكم لعلكم
تتقون
سبحانه وتالى اياما
معددا
enar day ised الله سبحانه وتالى said
counted days me an end and as we looking
for the crent ofan we saw the moon of
and now
we moon ising shrinking down is
disappear so everything in this earth
that has a beginning
الحد
الع الله سبحانه وتالى
was الله سبحانه وتالى ان الذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات انا لا نضيع اجر من احسن
ously inde
will was the
‏as الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله حث رول الله صلى الله عليه واله
وصحبه
وسلم بني ادم
خطا immune
from and mistakes
‏nature all are
the all people out
weakness against
وى do not
want
النفسه
ev and ego ands push us make and against
الله سبحانه
وتالى
outes
reg
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله وخلق ال انسان
ضعي
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى no matter how they look away from
the no matter how ma sin they do no how
out no that
for out them and up
he
الله
ex
ex ع رح الله
تالى
تعح رسول الله صلى الله
علول الفضيل بن عياض
was
compl from سانه he was a band he was the
head gangster grou he would he had s in
ay that anybody crosses this he will
take his money unjustly they will kill
them thaty
wass
‏take سبحانه
وتالى
one
girl
soed with her all
times think think i need
me me her so
heci that one of the nights i'm go to
her house up you know wall the fence and
go inside
‏let me make there
nole
make الله سبحانه وتعالى الم يان للذين
امنوا ان تخشع قلوبهم لذكر وما نزل من
الحق
‏heart dev
humble سبحانه وتالى and come them tru
and words الله سبحانه
وتالى of no preparation for him shook
him to hise shook him completely and he
and said yes my lord the time has come
yes my come
and الض ع
عانه
وتالى
180s
more
سهال
ع
حالى
‏out them الله سبحانه وتالى قل يا عبادي
الذين اسرفوا على على انفسهم لا تقنطوا من
رحمه الله say
my ex against
soul
not mercy الله ان الله يغفر الذنب جميعا
الله all انه هو الفور
الرحيم all
all الله سبحانه
وتالى without any any
regs
some سبهالى
الله سبحانه وتالى ساصرف عن اي الذين
يتكبرون في الارض بغير
الحق وان يروا كل ايه لا يؤمن
بها will
it these people hearts
سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى قد كانت اياتي
تتلى عليكم فكنتم على
اعقابكم
my الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبانه
وتالى
اللهانه
وتال days ضان الله سبحانه وتالى ان الله
يحب التبين
indeed those often over over indicating
may over
and اللهانه وتالى رول الله صلى الله عليه
التائب من الذنب كمن لا ذنب
لهان الله سبحانه
وتالى
رمضان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وصحبه وسلم
بعدا لمن ادرك رمضان ولم يغفر له رسول
الله
له فيه
فتان سبحانه
وتالى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بني
ادم
خطاء وخير الخطائين
التوابون الله اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله
العظيم لي ولوالدي ولكم ولسائر المسلمين
فيا فوز المستغفرين استغفر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله حمدا
كثيرا كما امر
الله ونشكره فانه قد وعد المزيد لمن
شكر ونشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك
له
الله اقرارا بربوبيته وغاما لمن جحد به
وكفر
ونشهد ان سيدنا محم صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم النبي
المعتبر محد صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم صلى الله عليه واله وسلم اتصلت عين
بنظر او سمعت اذن
بخبر
الله عباد الله الله اتقوا الله فيما امر
في
وانهوا ع نهاكم عنه
وزجر الله واخرجوا حب الدنيا من قلوبكم
فانه اذا استولى
اسر دنيا واعلموا انكم غدا بين يدي الله
موقوفون وباكم
محاسبون وعلى رب العزه سترضون
وسيعلم الذين ظلموا اي منقلب
ينقلبون واعلموا ان سيده عائشه رضي الله
عنها قالت كان صلى الله عليه واله وسلم
اذا دخل العشر احيا ليله وشد مئزره وايق
اهله رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وال وصحه
وسلم وقالت رضي الله عنها كان رسول الله
صلى الله عليه واله وسلم يجتهد في رمضان
ما لا يجتهد في
غيره
رض الله ان ربك يعلم انك تقوم ادنى من
ثلثي الليلن
وثث عليه الصه
والسلام صلى الله عليه وصح وسلم السده
عائشه وكان يجتهد في العشر ما لا يجتهد في
[Silence]
اللهانه وعلموا ان الله قد امركم بامر
عميم بدا بنفسه وثنى بملائكه قدسه
عز من قائل علي الله تشريفا لقدر نبيه
ولنا
تعلي ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا تسليما سمعنا
واطعنا اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
وبارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في العالمين
انك حميد مجيد وارضى اللهم عن الاربعه
الخلفاء الساده الحنفاء سادتنا وموالي
الكرام خير هذه الامه بعد النبي على
التحقيق وصاحبه في الفرج والضيق خليفه
رسول الله ابي بكر الصديق وعن الناطق
بالحق والصواب شهيد المحراب امير المؤمنين
عمر بن الخطاب وعن جامع القران صهر النبي
العدنان من استحيت منه ملائكه الرحمن ذي
النورين عثمان بن عفان وعن ولي نبيك وابن
عمه وباب مدينه علمه امير المؤمنين الغالب
علي بن ابي طالب ورضى اللهم عن سبطيه سيدا
شباب اهل الجنه وريحانته بنص السنه ابي
محمد الحسن وابي عبد الله الحسين ورضى
اللهم عن امهما فاطمه الزهرا وعن جدتهما
خديجه الكبرى ورضى اللهم عن ام المؤمنين
عائشه الرضا الصديقه بنت الصديق وارضى
اللهم عن سار ازواج نبيك امهات امهات
المؤمنين وارضى اللهم عن الحمزه والعباس
وسائر اهل بيت نبيك المطهرين من الدنس
والارجاء وارضى اللهم عن الصحابه اجمعين
وعن التابعين وتابع التابعين ومقلديه
باحسان الى يوم الدين وارضى اللهم عنا
معهم بفضلك وجودك ورحم ورحمتك وكرمك يا
اكرم الاكرمين اللهم يا ارحم الراحمين يا
ارحم الراحمين يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
ارحمنا وارحم امه نبينا محمد صلى الله
عليه واله وسلم رحمه عامه شامله واسعه لا
تغادر احدا لا في مشرق ولا في مغرب يا رب
العالمين اللهم بارك لنا في الحرمين
الشريفين وسلم ورد لنا اولى القبلتين
اللهم ارفع البلاء وتسلط الاعداء يا رب
العالمين عن عبادك المسلمين المستضعفين
المظلومين في فلسطين وفي غزه خصوصا اللهم
كن لهم عونا ومعينا وحافظا وناصرا وامينا
اللهم احقن دمائهم اللهم ثبت اقدامهم
اللهم اربط على قلوبهم اللهم ثبت الايمان
في قلوبهم اللهم يا رب انصرهم اللهم يا
ربنا انصرهم اللهم يا ربنا انصرهم اللهم
اطعم جائع وامن خائفيه واوي مشرديه يا رب
وانتقم من اعدائهم اللهم عليك بالصهاينه
المعتدين فانهم لا يعجزونك اللهم اقتلهم
بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تغادر منهم احدا
اللهم ابعث عليهم عاجل نقمتك في اليوم
والغدا اللهم اقذف في قلوبهم الخوف والقلق
والهلع والرعب والشقاق والفراق يا رب
العالمين اللهم ارنا فيهم يوما اسودا
عبوسا قمطريرا اللهم ارنا فيهم يوما كيوم
فرعون وقارون وهامان يا رب
العالمين اللهم انتق منهم اللهم انتقم
منهم اللهم اللهم منزل الكتاب مجري السحاب
هازم الاحزاب اهزمهم اللهم اكفنا بما شئت
وكيف شئت انك على كل شيء قدير واشف بذلك
صدور وقلوب قوم المؤمنين يا رب العالمين
اللهم ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار اللهم اعنا
على ذكرك وشكرك وحسن عبادتك ولا تجعلنا من
الغافلين اللهم اعنا على الصيام والقيام
وغض البصر وحفظ اللسان وتلاوه القران
اللهم بارك لنا في فيما بقي من شهر رمضان
اللهم وبلغنا فيه ليله القدر يا رب
العالمين اللهم اجعلنا فيها من المقبولين
واجعلنا فيها من الفائزين الغانمين يا رب
العالمين ولا تجعلنا فيها من المحرومين
ولا تجعلنا فيها من المحرومين ولا تجعلنا
فيها من المحرومين يا رب العالمين اللهم
انا نستغفرك فاغفر لنا اللهم انا نستغفرك
فاغفر لنا اللهم انا نستغفرك فاغفر لنا
اللهم ارزقنا جميعا توبه نصوحا يا رب
العالمين اللهم ارزقنا اليوم الان توبه
نصوحا لا ننكثه ابدا يا رب العالمين يا رب
ارزقنا توبه النصوحه تطهرنا بها قلبا
وجسدا وروحا يا حنان يا منان يا رب
العالمين اللهم تب على المذنبين يا رب تب
على المذنبين يا رب تب علينا لنتوب اليك
يا رب العالمين واكتبنا عندك من عبادك
التائبين التوابين المستغفرين المتطهرين
يا اكرم الاكرمين ويا حنان يا منان ربنا
اغفر لنا ولوالدينا ربنا ارحمهم كما ربونا
صغارا ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا وذرياتنا
قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما اللهم يا
فالق الحب والنوى اعط لكل واحد منا ما نوى
وزدنا من فضلك وجودك وكرمك يا رب العالمين
اللهم انا نسالك ان تدخل العيد بالفرحه
والامن والامان على المسلمين في كل مكان
يا حنان يا منان يا رب العالمين وصل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم
عباد الله ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا
الله يذكركم وادعوه يستجب لكم ولذكر الله
اكبر والله يعلم ما تصنعون اقم الصلاه
وقوموا الى
صلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على الصلاه حي
على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح حي على الفلاح قد
قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استوا استقيموا الى الصلاه ارحمني
ارحمكم الله سووا صفوفكم ولا تختلفوا سدوا
الخلل
والفرج
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الددين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذ الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فج له
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليه م غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم هل اتاك حديث الغاشيه وجوه يومئذ
خاشعه عامله ناصبه تصلى نارا حاميه تسقى
من عين انيه ليس لهم طعام الا من
ضريع لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع وجوه يومئذ
ناعمه لسعيها راضيه في جنه عاليه لا تسمع
فيها لاغيه فيها عين جاريه فيها سرر مرفو
عه
واكواب موضوعه ونمارق
مصفوفه وزرابي
مبثوثه افلا ينظرون الى الابل كيف خلقت
والى
السماء كيف رفعت والى الجبال كيف نصبت
والى الارض كيف سطحت فذكر
انما انت مذكر لست عليهم بمسيطر الا من
تولى وكفر فيعذبه الله العذاب الاكبر ان
الينا
ايابهم ثم ان علينا
حسابهم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
كم
127000 so
[Silence]
would
الله
[Silence]
‏some
some
make
something
‏what that helpful to us now coule
announ like
makeing
anding so that's don't want confuse
any
morning me 330
am morning
[Silence]
morning ‏i